[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day the rapper
yg was kicked off of a flight because
they said that he was drunk he said he
was sober he post about it on Twitter
Ainsley roll that tape uh
American Airlines over us they kicked me
off the planet somehow I'm Trump so what
we go they keep the planet said I'm I'm
sober today this is my favorite part
just to walk away which just feels like
cuz I've been there when you're trying
to prove you're not drunk so you're like
walk watch how straight I can walk
around when I was in college might go to
when I was trying to prove that I was
sober I would be like I'm sober asked me
any question as if that was proof that I
could answer what what do you guys do
when you're done how do you guys prove
that you're sober when you're obviously
drunk I don't prove once I start saying
to myself yeah I definitely sober I'm
definitely drunk
[Laughter]
like don't let him in it's so much
easier not to like aren't we all trying
to be drunk on an airplane yeah but I
want you to get drunk while you're in
flight and not be a little drunk by the
time I'm stepping onto the plane and
then I try to get a I would try to stay
drunk he's blanks give it away
yeah it's the cuz I do that too I am a
sleepy drunk so I'll be like I'm not
it's like I take two second apps you
know just to come back alive that's a
quick little recheck
when was the pause at the end of the
video was like I'm sober ISM girl and
then it was just just claiming that
you're the most sober yeah
I'm sober than anyone in the history of
the world my thing is when I'm drunk I
say I am absolutely drunk let's go have
a good time you can you can say you're
drunk as long as you're not like to the
point where they can't handie you if you
can't if you can't say that you're drunk
clearly they know you're gonna be a
problem but the guy walks in like dude I
had way too many guys want to take my
seat they're like oh that's cool cuz
they know you're gonna be quiet cuz you
know you have a problem if you know
you're drunk or you have them I think
they should make that update an update
that Southwest Airlines just made to
keep this plane discussion going
they just officially announced Ainslie
can you throw that up they said that
effective September 17th they're
clarifying their service animal and
emotional support animal policies right
now on you're only allowed to have dogs
or cats as emotional support animals
evidently this means no more support
snakes so I guess people we're taking on
snakes too airplanes anyone have any
comments about that
to do the same
[Laughter]
oh I guess you don't pick hearsay next
to anyway but it's since Southwest is
such a bitch to board if I were to be
like cafeteria seating they just like
open the door and go get in there
somebody with a snake what do they
provide for you for emotional support
what this you can still bring three
ponies where do you the article said you
can have up to three train service and
yes current reporter yeah three ponies
three well I think they're real forty
people but then people take advantage
you can just on Amazon by the little
dollars to get a fake ID for it dog yeah
and I think the dog has become a an
addictive drug to my dad in a weird way
like he loves the dog so much it's kind
of like you it's unhealthy Ryan has an
unhealthy amount of affection for his
dog Willie she's sweet at baby dog Lilly
on Instagram there's nothing wrong with
how much I love my dog and if she could
wear a little vest and get on an
airplane then that's fine I don't care
if it cost me a hundred dollars
I'm not bringing a snake on the plane so
don't come at me with that bull okay I
understand if you need it
but what emotional it's like this is
just like what we discuss I mean it's
like I'm the most normal
I think we need something to bring us
together so I've got one more story I
want to bring up on Instagram Ainsley
could you bring this up on the lush
account Lush Cosmetics this photos going
viral because everyone's saying that
this employee looks like Leonardo
DiCaprio real quick lightning round
what's earth Ryan does this look like
Leo no absolutely not no no career
together I mean I would you would smash
I'm probably gonna regret this we asked
what's your public urination strategy
and so so paucity on o Machiavelli says
a game me and my friends like to call
sneaky wheeze so all you need is a group
of mates and a full bladder and air in
an area like a street or on the dance
floor anywhere you shouldn't be
expelling liquid then get them to make a
circle around you while they're dancing
make a distract making a distraction BAM
that's when you unleash the piss
it works for guys and gals give it a go
next time team ok I don't think we
necessarily recommend that but thank you
for the comment
up next Ryan is gonna interview stand-up
comedian Casey James Salenko what's up
we're here with Casey James Solanco
who's recording his live podcast tonight
the good dad and the ugly at Caroline's
on Broadway 7:30 get there to get
tickets look folks we're gonna play a
game now with the case man mm-hmm that's
called how old is Casey and to explain
why Kacie Celino I have a pituitary
gland problem and you can never tell
hold I am an apparent
we're gonna make a game of that team
over here what's your name Minority
Report with Larry Wilmore the minority
team see the whole thing and over the
ladies round number one let's see how
old you think Casey is my bad boy here
this is for us so this camera looks so
shitty and this camera does look shitty
poor yes 13 no for the steel the
minority 17 no closer 16 the score is 0
to 0 our next photo Wow who does this go
to first Minority Report with Larry
Maher oh I feel like he looks the same
he's a little older because he's on the
mower I wouldn't trust a kid with a
mower
maybe the summer job like a college in
between ok hold on I don't want to
interrupt your thought process but that
man is definitely not at work oh yeah
you've definitely got a job he's drunk
and look at the flip flap in the
background all right give us your answer
23:23 no a quart of Steel no but close
like prices right style and just go one
color no I'm not very close guys I was
22 my summer job would be very
irresponsible zero to zero
oh this one is gonna go to the ladies
first okay give us our real name we
worked really hard on it so ladies and
gentlemen power
thank you Undertaker t-shirt right Sam
what we're not doing middle fingers but
Casey likes this hands up thing I think
then he looks at women just when I think
maybe middle school but then we gotta go
up so I think high school I don't think
that was high school but he's got a
pituitary issue we have to go a decade
chubby in middle school trust me okay 12
not 12 Minority Report with Larry
Wilmore okay 14 that is correct we have
one more picture what is an acceptable a
was when he kissed his dad oh I'm glad
is his dad so let's just talk this out
an acceptable age to kiss your dad on
the Oh what are you 26 if you become the
dope you do stop grabbing your dad's
face the older you get the less grab you
get with the hand I would say it has to
be middle school or under because you
only would think say oh I didn't kiss a
lady yet so I don't understand right
this is weird when I touch my dad sees
11:11 I am NOT 11 very mushy power
I think 24
[Laughter]
because I hate losing his hands are so
big but that could mean a different
thing than a that's true we don't know
how many gland issues case there's a lot
of glands man body butter all what did
they say eleven I want to say I will
back down for 24 okay I'm gonna go with
13 we can do 12 no no no what's it go
ladies I was 13 years 13 is not too old
because he doesn't know what it is too
old me kissing of this sensually we have
a one-to-one tie that means that we've
got to go to the lightning round does
the lightning round
how old is Casey right now 34 ladies 31
Casey I am 32 and also his half hour the
big man Thank You Casey for joining us
when I was in the second row of a modest
mouse concert and I didn't want to leave
and I had a water bottle and I had to
pee so I put the water bottle into my
pants and then put my hands down and put
my penis into the water bottle and peed
inside it no there was UPF there was too
much it wasn't there
what made your side I'm able to clamp it
off so I filled it up to about the top
clamped it off probably spilled a little
bit close the water bottle put it on the
floor and enjoyed the concert what did
everyone do around you um I don't think
anyone notice
okay another sign of the drug is when
you think you're pissin if no one knows
I was the most sober when I said that
yeah we'll see you next time
[Music]